ok voilà ce qu'on va faire et c'est non
négociable
tu as une journée sur à condition que tu
sois négatif aux tests urinaires que tu
vas devoir faire tueur est clean pendant
que tu es là et à cette heure si demain
je te ramène directement des attaques ce
n'était pas fini
c'est la règle études publiées et si ça
dérange j'en ai rien à [ __ ] je ne
lâcherai pas une seconde que tu le
veuilles ou non tu ne ferment pas la
porte de sa chambre qui soit dit en
passant ce sera aussi la mienne puisque
je dormirai par terre au cas où tu
voudrais essayer de fuguer citons
sommier fait le moindre petit crissement
je te bondir est une vue que pendant les
prochaines 24 heures
tu es à moi et à moi seul c'est clair
secure hockey
je ne savais pas quoi cévennes tu as vu
il a repris du poids et il a retrouvé sa
petite étincelle dans les yeux ça se
voit il va beaucoup mieux alors pourquoi
tu caches tout nos affaires on avait dit
qu'on revivrai pas ça tu te souviens tu
as une journée demain à cette heure si
tu repars en désintox
ok je ne quitterai pas des yeux une
seconde c'est clair c'est bien rentrer à
la maison
si tu me connaissait vraiment tu
voudrais plus jamais me voir je te
connais non non non non tu ne connais
pas tout ce que je veux c'est que tu
fasses un dernier petit truc pour moi
ceci est mon fils nommé yang ou pas il
faut que tu rentres à la maison
non pas son père
retrouvez mon fils fait
tout ce que je me suis infligé à moi et
aux autres
peut pas les sauver mais tu t'en voudra
toute ta vie si tu ne sais pas
ou est ce que tu veux que je t'en terre
dis-moi tu as ton cul
à mourir
enfin bref voilà je suis toujours là
alors merci à tous merci beaucoup
[Musique]